the biden administration grows ever more
radical as it seeks to promote an
alleged former eco-terrorist to high
office
crammed through a massive budget bill
and re-mask americans i'm ben shapiro
this is the ben shapiro show
this show is sponsored by expressivevpn
it's time to stand up to big tech
protect your data at expressvpn.com
ben well you'll remember that joe biden
was elected on a couple of promises one
is that he would not be donald trump
which is a pretty easy promise to keep
all you have to do is not be donald
trump
the other is that he would not be alive
and on one hand he's kind of kept that
promise because
this president is not particularly
sentient every so often he gets into a
running gun battle with the teleprompter
and then loses every so often it appears
as though he's going to keel over in the
middle of his sentence so on that score
he seems you know doddering
unthreatening but
one of the big promises of him not being
particularly alive was going to be that
he was not radical
and who's going to be a moderate that's
the reason he won the primaries against
bernie sanders it's the reason he won
against president trump again the entire
idea here is that joe biden was going to
be a return to normalcy candidate
was going to unify americans by ending
radical moves
the problem for joe biden is that his
entire administration is predicated it
sits atop the iceberg that is the
democratic party
and that iceberg has been gradually
drifting to the left
david shore who's a a statistician and
economist
he's of the left he points out that
basically all change in terms of policy
in terms of both parties has come from
the left since 2010.
the right the republican party has been
basically stagnant in terms of its
policy prescriptions
and positions since 2010 the democratic
party has been moving
ever more steadily to the left and
people of the left have begun to
acknowledge this they begin to
acknowledge yes we're getting more
radical now what they say is our
radicalism is justified
and good but there is no question that
joe biden
himself has moved to the left and this
administration which promised to be a
return
to some semblance of normalcy might be
more normal
in terms of joe biden not tweeting but
it is certainly less normal in terms of
policy this is always the greatest
disconnect with trump is that trump said
crazy things all the time but
trump's actual policy was mainstream
republican policy
very often embracing centrist policy in
terms of spending proposals
his foreign policy was basically normal
hawkish republican foreign policy
although with more of a sort of
isolationist bent
than traditional american republican
foreign policy his tax policy was very
traditional republican policy
his domestic regulatory policy was
traditional republican policy joe biden
however
has stacked his administration with
people who are radicals his democratic
party
has decided to overthrow years
decades actually of bipartisan
agreements on key issues
so for example nancy pelosi has
announced that the democratic party is
going to ram through a revision of the
hyde amendment the height amendment has
been an agreement between democrats and
republicans that regardless of where you
stand on abortion
federal tax dollars should not be used
for individual abortions
federal tax dollars if you're going to
spend them at planned parenthood they're
supposed to be used to cover planned
parenthood's front office now we all
understand that there's a little bit
of a legal lie going on here that money
is fungible if you send planned
parenthood money to cover
its front office staff then all the
money they were going to use for their
front office staff they are now going to
be used for abortions but
at least the idea was that there was an
agreement between republicans and
democrats that abortion should not be
federally funded democrats however have
decided that abortion is an overt good
it is not that abortion ought to be safe
legal and rare as in the clinton days
which at least allowed for the
possibility
of some crossover between left and right
on abortion policy because after all
if the left acknowledges that abortion
is a moral tragedy and even if they want
it to remain legal they are not at least
pro-abortion but the democratic party
has now embraced an abortion the sort of
shout your abortion idea be proud of
your abortion abortion
isn't merely a horrible thing that
sometimes is necessary as democrats
used to argue now abortion is a point of
pride you can't actually
usher yourself into the full flower of
womanhood another word that has no
meaning according to the democrats
unless you have an abortion lena dunham
said this uh fairly openly a few years
ago when she said she wishes she had had
an abortion
so that she could have really enjoyed
the full freedoms
of the law well nancy pelosi and joe
biden both of whom
used to basically go along with the
consensus view that federal taxpayer
dollars should not be used for abortion
now they've reversed themselves joe
biden did it a couple of years ago he
had said that
he was in favor of the height amendment
then he reversed himself because he
needed to move to the left now nancy
pelosi is saying the same thing
now one of the great i think annoyances
for many catholics in the country
watching joe biden and nancy pelosi say
this stuff is that very often they say
this stuff in the name of catholicism
and i'm gonna go with the pope and jesus
not super huge on abortion i don't have
to be
a christianity expert to point out that
abortion has been sort of a major issue
for the catholic church
since literally the entire catholic
church but here's nancy pelosi
making the case that abortion is
actually a positive good taxpayers
should fund abortion
she starts off by talking about her
catholic faith and then she's like ah my
catholic thing
and she just kind of throws it out the
window here we go
as a devout catholic and mother of five
in six years
i feel that god blessed my husband and
me
with our beautiful family five children
six years almost to the day
but that may not be what we should it's
not up to me to
dictate that that's what other people
should do
and it it's an issue of fairness and
uh justice for poor women in in our
country it's
an issue of fairness and justice that
poor women should be able to kill babies
in the womb sure
my husband and i were blessed by god
with these five or six kids but if we've
been if we've been
poor and if we just want to kill one of
them well
who are we to judge so the democratic
party in terms of policy
has moved in pretty radical directions
here
and it's been true throughout the
administration this is why they've
embraced quote unquote equity as the
core
of all of the things they do from nasa
to commerce
from education to the department of the
interior from transportation
to whatever is joe biden's policy
prescription of the day it's all equity
and equity of course is a code word for
group social justice on the basis of
race and this has been embraced by the
entire obama admin
but i say obama but it really is the
biden administration which is the third
part of the obama administration
here's gina raimondo biden's commerce
secretary yesterday
saying that equity is at the core of her
commerce strategy which again i don't
know why
it's not the department of equity in
fact the department of equity would be
unconstitutional because equity itself
as a concept
violates the equal protection clause of
the 14th amendment but
here is here is gina raimondo claiming
that equity ought to be at the center of
commerce
our number one investment priority is
equity
and as our team decides which these are
this is a competitive grant process
by the way i think that the fact of the
competition
will help communities to come together
as a community
and and put their best ideas forward in
order to qualify to get the money you
have to prove to us
that equity you'll have an equity lens
okay that's insane so she's saying we
have a competitive process but the
competitive process is not about
best product lowest price which normally
when you're negotiating on the behalf of
taxpayers for grant money
that's usually the process now the
process is about can you prove to us
that you mirror our political priorities
can you prove to us that you are
committed to equity and by equity we
mean you have a certain number of black
people on your board and we have a
certain number of gay people on your
board that's that's how we're going to
make sure that equity
is assured right this is very radical
stuff from the federal government and
the federal government not only has no
business doing this it's
pretty clearly violative of
constitutional principles
first of all it should be violative of
constitutional principles to force
taxpayers to pay for abortions it should
also it's clearly violative of
constitutional
federal principles as well as the civil
rights act of 1964
to suggest that the federal government
can dole out money to particular
businesses based on how many people of a
particular melanin level
are on their board right that that
i i'm unaware of at a time in american
history where the people who are
stumping in favor of racial
discrimination
are the good guys but this is the biden
administration and they have
at the top this man approaching senility
who is able to put sort of a friendly
face on this sort of stuff but
the underlying policy is really really
radical and many of the people who are
staffing the administration
are really radical it's kind of amazing
the kinds of people who have been
staffed in this administration
and we've seen the doj staffed by
absolute radicals people
who have written extraordinarily
racially radical things people who have
been
openly opposed to policing now staffing
up the civil rights division of the doj
now we have a nominee to lead the bureau
of land management
right which is all about negotiating the
needs
of people like ranchers and farmers who
have to use the land in order to produce
and the and the federal government's
vast oversight of huge quantities of
land like people i think don't have any
idea
of how much control the the bureau of
land management has
over various swaths of state they have
oversight of 247.3
million acres 247.3
million acres and the amount of land
they have control of in each state
is utterly crazy if you look at the map
basically it's the entirety of the state
of nevada blm has control
not black lives matter the bureau of
land management has control over nearly
all of nevada
it has huge control over arizona it has
big control over new mexico
i mean if you look at the map it really
is amazing like once you get to the west
of nebraska
pretty much half the country is under
the control of the bureau of land
management
huge swaths of california huge swaths of
idaho
huge swaths of oregon
two-thirds of wyoming right so the
bureau of land management's a pretty
important position
so running the bureau of land management
you don't want somebody who's for
example an environmental radical because
if you have somebody who's an
environmental radical and
in charge of the bureau of land
management presumably that person is
going to crack down on the ability
of farmers and ranchers to do what they
want to do you'll remember that it was
exactly
this sort of conflict that led to the
standoff with the bundy family
in nevada you remember this well now who
is joe biden
nominating to be the head of the bureau
of land management
it's a woman named tracy stone so who
the hell is tracy stone
it turns out that tracy's stone went in
the 1980s
she worked with essentially an
eco-terrorist group and what they used
to do is spike trees
so spiking trees was something that
radical environmentalists would do in
areas that were about to be used for
lumber they would go in
and they would nail nails they would
spike the trees they would put spikes
metal spikes into the trees in order to
break the saws and presumably injure and
harm the people who are attempting to
cut down the trees because the trees
are more important than the people
according to the washington post one
spring day
in 1989 tracy stone rented a typewriter
from the university of montana library
and began to retype a letter the
typewriter was to avoid using her
personal computer
the letter was an anonymous warning to
the u.s forest service that someone
had hammered hundreds of metal spikes
into trees in an idaho forest that was
slated to be cut down for timber
an acquaintance in her circle of young
environmentalists had asked her to send
it
after fixing a few spelling mistakes and
removing some profanity stone dropped in
the mail
it was a decision that has followed her
now tracy stone manning for more than 30
years
through her rise in montana politics to
become one of the country's most
prominent environmentalists
and public land experts and now
president biden's nominee
to lead the bureau of land management
the letter led to law enforcement raids
on student houses and a grand jury
investigation her testimony in the
subsequent trial would help send two
people to federal prison
now that stone manning's nomination is
in the senate republican opponents have
seized on the
it's pouncing it's pouncing okay so the
fact that you have an environmental
radical so radical that she was working
with people to spike trees possibly kill
loggers
her nomination is just another
republican seizing moment republican
pouncing moment
senator john barrasso republican of
wyoming who's on the senate energy and
natural resources committee said tracy
stoman collaborated with eco-terrorists
a bureau of land management director
during the obama administration bobby
abbey
also said he opposed her confirmation
okay again this is an obama
administration official because of her
involvement in the tree spiking incident
and quote the fact that her initial
silence put people at risk apparently
she did not cooperate
with prosecutors in that case
however jeff fairchild who spent two
months in federal prison for the tree
spiking said in a phone interview
quote other than the mailing of the
letter tracy knew nothing was not
involved she was a bridge builder she
was a moderating voice in every
discussion she was always the one to say
hey look
loggers have families too well i mean if
that's the case then why did she send a
letter
trying to explain to people that the
trees had been spiked
by the way here is here is what the um
actual letter says okay in case you were
wondering
again she wrote this she or at least
transcribed it quote
to whom it may concern this letter is
being sent to notify you that the post
office sale in idaho has been spiked
heavily the reasoning for this action is
that this place
this piece of land is very special to
the earth it is home to the elk
deer mountain lions birds and especially
the trees
like the lore actually speaks for the
trees the project required that's 11 of
us spent nine days in god-awful weather
conditions
spiking trees we unloaded a total of 500
pounds of spikes measuring eight to ten
inches in length
the sails were marked so no workers
would be injured and so you a-holes
know that they are spiked the majority
of trees were spiked within the first
ten feet
many many others were spiked as high as
150 feet i'd be more than willing to pay
you a dollar for the sale but you would
have to find me first
and that could be your worst nightmare
sincerely george heyduke ps you bastards
go in there anyway and a lot of people
could get hurt and this is
pretty wild stuff and her history
is i think pretty dispositive of the
fact i mean this is not somebody who's
just a radical in college right this is
somebody who's actively working with an
eco-terrorist group
but according to the abaddon
administration this is a great nominee
and by the way her her
her actual vote has now emerged to the
full senate on a 10-10 vote on a
party-line vote in this particular
committee we'll get some more of this in
just
one second first there are a thousand
reasons why protecting our home matters
to me if somebody stops by
or something is going on outdoors around
the house ring will let me know it's
peace of mind anytime knowing our home
is protected
ring has a special offer for you right
now go to ring.com forward slash ben it
is the perfect way to start your ring
experience with rings home security
system when anyone stops by or you send
something going on outdoors around the
house you know ring has every corner of
your home covered one of the best
benefits you install the products
yourself the process is hassle free
your whole home is protected with easy
to install indoor and outdoor cams
and get this the cams work seamlessly
with ring alarm
you see what's happening from anywhere
all in one very simple app it's never
been more important to have a reliable
home security system
and please my family and i can keep an
eye on our home no matter where we are
right from our phone
and know when those packages are
delivered protect your home anytime
anywhere with ring alarm go to ring.com
for a special offer on a ring alarm
security kit you can build the system
right for your home have it up and
running
in minutes my wife and i have ring alarm
all over our house we have the
the cameras we make sure that we can
keep an eye on our kids we want to know
what's going on in our property even
when we're out of town
ring makes it happen for us they can do
the same for you ring.com
once more that is ring.com ben
so again the the notion that the bottom
administration is going to be
elevating to high position
as the head of the bureau of land
management there are all these
government agencies that honestly have
so much unbelievable power that you've
never heard of
like how many people particularly in big
cities have ever heard of the bureau of
land management
not many but if you are a rancher if
you're a logger
if you're a farmer if you're anybody who
has to do anything with the land
anywhere west of nebraska
then not only have you heard of the
bureau of land management they basically
can wreck your life
and the person that the bible
administration wants to elevate to this
position of unbelievable power
is a person who used to spike trees on
behalf of radical environmentalists or
at least defend
those who are spiking trees
the atmosphere was so tense at the 1993
trial of these eco-terrorists in the
conservative city of spokane washington
where stone manning testified defendants
were given bulletproof vests to get to
the courthouse
stone manning has long offered a simple
defense for her decision to mail the
anonymous letter
on the sabotage in the clearwater
national forest about two hours from
campus
because i wanted people to know the
trees were spiked she testified i didn't
want anybody getting hurt as a result of
trees being spiked
the four-paragraph letter she mailed put
it a lot more bro a lot more bluntly
jake crelick met stone manning in
washington in 1988 according to the
washington post before she moved to
missoula when they were both interns at
the national wildlife federation
a child of the beltway who grew up in
silver spring stone manning and majored
in radio film and tv as an undergrad at
university of maryland
but she was passionate about
environmental issues krilik recalled and
once she enrolled in the university of
montana's environmental studies program
she became active alongside him in a
local branch of earth first the group
had a reputation for extreme frontline
environmental activism and opposition to
logging dam building and other
development that threatened
wilderness habitat tactics included
civil disobedience and vandalism
activists chained themselves to heavy
machinery laid down before bulldozers
and cut power lines
their slogan no compromise in defense of
mother earth
mother earth credit's earth first debut
occurred in the winter of 1985 when he
and others barged into the office
of yellowstone national park
superintendent bob barbie carrying
buffalo dung in a don't tread on me flag
to protest the expansion of a campground
and rv park into grizzly bear habitat
he'd get arrested several more times
recalled crelic quote stone manning was
a spokesperson and someone who was
obviously very articulate knew how to
work with the media
certainly she was philosophically
aligned with what our goals were which
was to protect the last wilderness areas
in the northern rockies okay so senator
john barrasso
went after tracy stone manning in his in
in her questioning the other day and of
course he is exactly right
tracy stone manning collaborated with
eco-terrorists
she lied to this committee and she
continues to harbor extremist views
most americans find reprehensible she is
thoroughly disqualified from holding the
important position of director of the
bureau of land management
in 1989 while a grad student in montana
tracy stone manning collaborated with
eco-terrorists
who had hammered hundreds of metal
spikes
into trees in a national forest
by the way she did lie to the senate
according to john barrasso
ms stoneman and claims should quote
never been arrested or charged and to my
knowledge the target of such an
investigation
that's not true according to court
documents and news reports stone manning
was investigated in 1989 federal probe
of the tree spiking conspiracy
she was subpoenaed to provide physical
evidence including hair samples
she admitted in 1990 she was an
investigative target her experience she
said was quote degrading
it changed my awareness of the power of
government yes this was happening to me
and not someone in panama so manning
also claimed
she later testified in a trial that
resulted in the conviction of a
responsible individual
that's part of the story but the reality
is she did not cooperate with
investigators
a retired federal law enforcement agent
who is the lead investigator for the
crime wrote to the senate saying she
helped plan the spiking
and was a target of the investigation
and refused to do anything to help
her intransigence set the probe back by
years only after she was caught and
offered immunity did she agree to
testify
against one of these spikers in 1993 and
this is who joe biden believes would be
an excellent pick to lead up the bureau
of land management because again
it's a radical administration some of us
warned about this before the election of
joe biden
but some people did not listen meanwhile
the democrats continue
to ram forward their massive spending
plans
so there are a couple of things that are
on the table right now there is the
senate bipartisan infrastructure plan in
which you have senator mitt romney
senator rob portman who have
signed on to this sort of thing and the
idea here is 1.2 trillion dollar
bipartisan infrastructure plan
but the byte administration has made
extraordinarily clear their actual plans
here anything that doesn't make it
into the 1.2 trillion dollar quote
unquote bipartisan plan
gets squeezed on over into the 3.5
trillion dollar budget plan
and it turns out that bernie sanders is
in control of that process because he
and his fellow radical senators and his
fellow radicals in the house have
decided they're going to hold
up the giant democrat-only
infrastructure plan unless
it grows even more according to cnbc
the republicans working to craft the 1.2
trillion proposal voted wednesday
against advancing it as they draft final
legislation for some odd reason
chuck schumer decided he was going to
bring up the legislation for a vote
before it had even been drafted
despite the setback the 22 democratic
and gop senators drawing up the bill
said they hope to release and push ahead
a bill in the coming days according to
cnbc the vote leaves presidential
biden's top legislative priority in flux
if the bipartisan deal to revamp
transportation broadband and utilities
falls apart
democrats will have to consider whether
to pair physical infrastructure plans
with their separate 3.5 trillion
package to address climate change health
care and child care
asked wednesday during a cnn town hall
biden said he thinks the senate will
vote monday to advance the bipartisan
framework he negotiated
with the senators and the question here
is how much do you trust at joe manchin
because of course this is going to come
down to joe manchin
why republicans would work with
democrats if joe manchin and christian
cinema are just going to vote party line
in order to advance the inflated bill
along with the bipartisan bill i don't
know how republicans would provide any
level of cover
for that but here's the thing democrats
have no doubt about this they're just
going to ram this forward regardless
representative catherine catherine clark
democrat of connecticut says yeah we're
going to pass infrastructure pretty much
no matter what
they're going to pass because that is
what the american people sent us here to
do
they said to us in 2020 we want action
we want to be at the center of the
priorities again
that's why democrats won the white house
the house and the senate
it is not going to be easy our margins
are slim
but what we have in abundance is a
commitment to getting this done
okay so is this actually going to be
good for the economy here is where the
radicalism comes in we'll get to that in
just one second first let's talk about a
simple fact when you start a business
you really don't think about hr because
who does
hr is toby from the office but if you
don't actually think about hr it can
absolutely crush your business
it could come back to haunt you you need
to have great hr policy from the very
beginning
wrongful termination suits minimum wage
requirements labor regulations you got
to make sure you've got all of that
taken care of and hr manager salaries
can be like 70 grand a year
instead head on over to bambi bambi is
spelled b-a-m-b-e-e
it was created specifically for small
business you can get a dedicated hr
manager craft hr policy maintain your
compliance
all for just 99 bucks a month with bambi
you can change hr from your biggest
liability to your biggest strength
your dedicated hr manager is available
by phone email or real-time chat from
onboarding determinations they customize
your policies to fit your business and
help you manage your employees
day-to-day all for just 99 bucks a month
they're month-to-month no hidden fees
you can cancel any time you didn't start
your business because you wanted to
spend time on hr compliance
let bambi help get your free hr audit
today go to bambi.com
shapiro right now schedule that free hr
audit that is b-a-m-b-e-e
dot com shapiro spell b-a-m-b-e dot com
shapiro okay so how radical is the
democratic
budget policy joe manchin is pretty
skittish on it here was the senator from
west virginia yesterday saying
listen you know there are a bunch of
democrats trying to hold up this giant
budget bill because they want more
i don't know what they're talking about
here's joe manchin yesterday
how concerned about what your party is
talking about by climate change and what
that means for
the only thing we have a difference you
know that you've heard me talk on that
i'm an all-in policy i'm all in energy
we have to have everything
the united states of america has to be
energy and independent well what they're
proposing is that going to decimate your
interest well what they're proposing
that the
the timing of what they're proposing
would make it almost impossible
to achieve that
okay look again these policies are
really radical but joe biden wants his
world beating policy because he knows
that by the end of 2022 he ain't gonna
be in control of the house anymore the
republicans have a really
really good shot at taking back the
house in 2022
and increasingly a good shot at
retaining the senate as well or taking
it back rather
i think the democrats are going to lose
their seat in georgia there's a very
close race in new hampshire it looks
like democrats are slated to lose that
seat
as well there's a lot of talk about
wisconsin senator ron johnson
who has made some mistakes but has
overall been a pretty good senator from
wisconsin he's been talking about how he
might not want to run there are a bunch
of other republicans in wisconsin who
are pretty popular like representative
mike gallagher
he might run for the senate in wisconsin
in which case you could be looking at a
full republican congress by the end of
which means that joe biden needs to get
his world beating plans through right
now joe biden also understands he's in
all likelihood
the the single term a single term
president because frankly the man is in
decline it is clear that he is in
decline
he cannot hold it together i mean it is
pretty incredible
the running gun battle with the
teleprompter just it continues each and
every day he's just incoherent he
doesn't make any sense and so what that
means is if he wants to go down in
history as
a successful one-term president he knows
that the way the historians write the
record books
the more you spend the more the
historians love you
it is just a fact and it is unbelievable
it's an unbelievable fact actually if
you look at how historians rank
presidents in the 20th century
the way they tend to rank presidents in
the 20th century is the more you spend
the better you were
incredibly enough if you look at how
historians rank the presidents of the
1920s the 1920s were an excellent
decade for the united states the 1920s
were called the roaring 20s for a reason
yet calvin coolidge warren harding these
were terrible presidents fdr
who presided over the worst depression
in american history with crappy economic
policy pulled directly from his colon
he is considered like the best president
of the 20th century and the other
transformative president
is the guy who led us into vietnam led
to the morass of the war on poverty
spending 22 trillion dollars over the
subsequent half-century
and led to the societal breakdown of all
possible coherence in the united states
lbj
so it but historians love the guy so joe
biden knows this
and because joe bi because joe biden
knows this he's like okay i'm going to
spend up the wazoo and i'm going to
pretend that the consequences
that attend to spending are not in fact
a big deal
now here's the thing most americans are
not in on this so msnbc
they did a swing voter panel the other
day and remember this is an msnbc swing
voter panels this is not a right wing
panel
the msnbc swing voter panel was like
yeah these spending plans are crazy we
don't need that
we're in the middle of an economic
recovery that should be naturally
occurring
and if it weren't for the media scaring
the living hell out of everybody about
the
delta variant would be even more
naturally occurring we'll get to the
delta variants in just one second but
the swing voters are looking at joe
biden spending plans like this doesn't
make any sense at all what are you doing
i want to give you some findings that
really just get to the public's
collective
unease once you start getting to those
numbers we asked a question
where we said if there was that level of
spending what would concern you
and here's what we got we got 74 percent
would be concerned with runaway
inflation
78 that it would be higher taxes on them
personally down the line
69 percent lower growth 69 percent a
negative impact on my family's
finances okay those are terrible stats
four job
remember that's a panel of swing voters
not democrats and not republicans swing
voters
those are huge numbers it's ryan clancy
from no labels talking about that
so what are the democrats doing they're
pushing full head
full forward ahead all speed so janet
yellen
who's the treasury secretary she's by
the way now changed her tune
she cautioned on thursday that prices
could continue to rise for several
more months okay so remember at the
beginning of the year they were saying
it'll be mild inflation mild inflation
now the inflation is like five percent
it's at a five percent rate
over the prior year and it's increasing
like every single month
you can't get lumber you can't get
workers the unemployment rates actually
spiked
they're actually going up more people
are claiming unemployment now than they
were before
like as of like last month and yet joe
biden continues to push forward
with his plans it really is an amazing
thing remember janet yellen went from
inflation is not a big deal and will go
away very very fast it's transitory
to inflation might be around a little
longer than you want to yeah inflation's
just a part of life now
she said during a closing bell interview
on cnbc quote we'll have several more
months of rapid inflation
i'm not saying this is a one-month
phenomenon i think over the medium term
we'll see inflation decline back toward
normal levels but of course we have to
keep a careful eye on it well the
problem is once inflation starts to run
out of control you're going to get
economic contraction because if
inflation starts to run out of control
and the fed is already at zero percent
essentially when they raise the rates
what do you think is going to happen
it's gonna make lending harder but it's
gonna make lending harder at a time
when the prices are higher which leads
to a slowing of the economy
once you start to super heat the account
this is the problem with central banks
taking control of economic policy
once they're in control of economic
policy and they've shot
their and they've shot their wad they've
used all their ammo there's nothing more
they can do if the economy
just starts to stagnate they really have
no choice this is how you end up with
stagflation 1970s style
stagflation and everybody knows it at
this point that's what's truly amazing
and you're starting to see the signs
very very early
like right now you can see that the
unemployment
statistics are beginning to actually
climb oddly enough now there's no reason
for that we have 10 million
open jobs we have 10 million open jobs
in the country right now and not enough
people to fill them people are just not
even applying
for the jobs and yet according to
cnbc the u.s jobless claims showed a
surprising
gain this is just a couple of days ago
weekly jobless claims unexpectedly moved
higher last week despite hopes that the
us labor market is poised for a strong
recovery
heading into the fall initial filings
for unemployment insurance totaled 419
000 for the week
ending july 17th well above the 350 000
dow jones estimate
and more than the upwardly revised 368
000 from the previous period the labor
department reported
on thursday government bond yields edged
lower wall street pointed to a negative
open
the jobless count was the highest weekly
account since may 15th
again remember we're supposed to be
getting people back to work now
even joe biden is having to admit some
truths here so biden admitted the other
day that
yeah unemployment benefits probably kept
people from working
there's some evidence that maintaining
the ability to continue
not to not have your have to pay your
rent so you don't get thrown out and
being able to provide for unemployment
insurance has kept people from going
back to work
there's no not much distinction between
not going back to work in a restaurant
and not going back to work at a at a
factory
so people are looking to change
opportunities change what they're doing
okay but meanwhile joe biden is also
just lying about his own policy
so joe biden said at the cnn town hall
which by the way had the worst ratings
of pretty much anything on cable tv
because no one wants to watch
a guy be asked questions about what his
flavor
of ice cream is like what's his favorite
flavor of ice cream here is joe biden
being asked about his spending bills and
inflation again his own treasury
secretary says we're going to look at
many more months of rapid inflation here
is joe biden being like no no my
spending bills are going to bring down
inflation
which is real galaxy brain type stuff
here
moody's today when our wall street firm
not some liberal think tank
said if we pass the other two things i'm
trying to get done
we will in fact reduce inflation
reduce inflation reduce inflation
because we're going to be providing good
opportunities and jobs for people
who in fact are going to be reinvesting
that money
back in all the things we're talking
about driving down prices not raising
prices
um no moody's did not say that by the
way he's not even telling the truth
there what moody said
is they think that inflation will be
transitory and will eventually go away
but they did not say that inflation is
going to be reduced by spending money
okay when he says that if we blow money
into the economy it's going to reduce
inflation that is like me saying that if
i eat 10 000 calories a day i'm gonna
lose weight
there's no way that works the diff the
definition of inflation is more money
chasing fewer products if you create the
more money
you create the inflation everyone
understands this everybody knows this
except apparently joe biden who's just a
i will say he has been for nearly his
entire career a very very smooth liar
i remember when he debated paul ryan he
just would say things in in 2012 that
were overtly untrue i mean clearly
untrue
but he would say them with the weird
joker smile the caesar romero and
everybody go oh it must be true
well what he just said there makes no
sense at all it is absolutely incoherent
but it's okay we don't expect coherence
from this president here is the
president of the united states also
oddly bragging about
delaware's corporate record he's talking
about how he knows how business operates
because
a lot of businesses incorporate in
delaware you know why businesses
incorporate in delaware
i know because i business is
incorporated in delaware you know why
businesses incorporate in delaware
because delaware for many businesses
does not have corporate tax
also delaware has very predictable rules
of the road
which is why people incorporate until
we're in the first place in fact all the
things that joe biden hates
about delaware are the things that make
delaware successful in terms of being an
incorporation center
for many businesses in the united states
here's joe biden talking about delaware
even though again he's had nothing to do
with the formation of state law in
delaware that has made it a corporate
haven
we have more corporations registered in
delaware than all
the rest of america combined
combined combined i represented for 30
women six years i've never seen a time
when we have the middle class growing
that the wealthy didn't do
very very very well
okay i i know his new mode of
communication
because the brain is not working all
that fast is just to repeat repeat
repeat words words
words over and over
and over right it's going inflation
is going to be reduced reduced reduced
i mean okay dude no matter how many
times you say it it just
ain't true it just ain't true i am
amused by the way by some of the
creative
proposals that are now being put forward
by folks on the left to tamp down
inflation and and fight the reality
which is that people are looking for
other sources
for investment value other than the
united states dollar in balance
one of the reasons by the way that
democrats are very skittish about
bitcoin for example is because bitcoin
is a repository of value that is not
tied to the united states dollar
so they're very scared of bitcoin
they're very scared of the idea that
there could be
theoretically a cryptocurrency that
people could trade in without reference
to the united states dollar could debase
the united states
dollar as actually the the reserve
currency if it were allowed to
run out of control which is why
governments are starting to crack down
on it but the solution that is now being
proposed which is a sort of fed coin
why would i possibly invest in a fed
coin when they can just inflate the fed
coin
that's the same thing as investing in
the dollar why would i do that i'm not
going to invest in anything that can be
manipulated by the central bank
it's precisely for that reason that
bitcoin was created in the first place
that cryptocurrencies were created in
the first place there will be
flight like you've never seen to crypto
if the if the democrats keep this sort
of stuff up
it really is an amazing thing that the
solution to failed government policy is
always what if we just manipulated the
government policy more
in fact if you don't like how we're
manipulating the dollar right now if you
don't like how we're manipulating
the the level of money in the economy
right now wait until we offer the same
thing to you
but digitally hell of a pitch there okay
in just a second we'll get to the
radical democratic coveted policy
which continues to be utterly
disconnected from reality get to that in
just one moment first
you've heard me talk a lot of weeks
about how much i love
my pillow product right well now my
pillow is not just making pillows
and they're not just making sheets
they're changing the game with their six
piece towel set the set is made with usa
cotton
makes it extremely absorbent it's still
providing that soft feel you look for in
a towel the set comes with a
two bath two hand towels two washcloths
typically retailing for 109.99 for a
limited time you get this set for the
very low price of 39.99 so from 109.99
to 39.99 that is a hell of a discount
in fact let me do the quick calculations
over 60 percent in savings
always remember all my pillow products
come with a 60-day money-back guarantee
you don't have anything to lose they
come in a variety of colors and sizes
they're the best hells i've used
in years they really are great okay if
you need like a nice soft absorbent to
tell let me tell you
my pillow tells excellent stuff you've
heard me talk about my pillows amazing
pillows and sheets now
they've perfected towels as well go to
mypillow.com click
on the radio listener square use promo
code dailywire at checkout or call
800-651-1148
you'll receive this amazing six piece
towel set for just 39.99 that is
mypillow.com
click on the radial listener square use
promo code daily wire again call
1-800-651-1148 use promo code dailywire
go to mypillow.com
make sure you use that promo code
dailywire also
my newest book authoritarian moment the
authoritarian moment it's about to hit
shelves this tuesday july 27th you need
to buy it right now but here is a
special deal
for you i've been getting a lot of
emails about how do i get a signed copy
here's how
if you haven't purchased your copy yet
you can get a limited edition signed
book for just 30 bucks at dailywire.com
that's a pretty good deal if you ask me
especially because i will be doing a
live stream book signing and q
a this coming tuesday you can submit a
question right now when you go to
purchase
your signed copy when you do you'll be
asked to type in a question at checkout
and then
watch tuesday's live signing to see if i
answer your question watch me
sign your book if i don't get to your
question don't worry you'll still get
your signed copy anyway what are you
waiting
for add to your signed books collection
by going to dailywire.com
ben right now it's also a better
investment value than us bonds as the
establishment media becomes increasingly
beholden to the leftist narrative by the
way
it's important that there's still a
space for conservative voices and that
is why we have launched
the highly successful show the morning
wire it's the morning podcast that
values your time
and the truth we're excited to see our
listeners already understand this
the podcast just launched this week it
is number two on apple overall number 11
on spotify
before the weekend we want it to be
number one so subscribe now to
morningwire
on apple spotify or wherever you listen
to podcasts leave a five star review
if you like what you hear it's brought
to you by daily wire editor in chief
john bickley i trust john so much that i
literally handed over my editor-in-chief
slots
to john right and he runs it along with
co-host george a hal
morning wire will wake you up with the
latest developments in politics sports
culture education all
with a heavy emphasis on the facts in 15
bite size minutes it's everything you
need to know
about the data news in 15 minutes
perfect for your daily commute so again
subscribe to morning wire on apple
podcast spotify and everywhere you
listen to podcasts so you don't miss a
beat
if you like what you hear leave a five
star review tell the podcast platforms
the conservative news belongs number one
on the charts you're listening to the
largest fastest growing conservative
podcast and radio show in the nation
[Music]
well meanwhile the biden administration
continues to pursue radical policy
with regard to masking i mean it truly
is an amazing amazing
thing okay so here are your latest stats
with regard to
vaccinations and covid because what
you're hearing from the media is the
coveted breakthroughs
with regard to vaccination are happening
all the time and not only
are they happening all the time people
are getting super sick or dying from
kovid even after they've been vaccinated
and all this does it's amazing the same
media
are screaming at republicans why don't
you get vaccinated are putting out
headlines routinely
talking about how people who are
vaccinated must wear masks because god
forbid
even if you're vaccinated you might get
the disease and you might die okay now
the reality is statistically speaking
you are extraordinarily unlikely to get
seriously ill or die
from covid after you've been double
daxed once you've been double vaxxed
you're in pretty good shape
hey i'm going to give you the stats
right now this is according to the new
york times as of july 12th more than 159
million people in the united states had
been fully vaccinated against cloven 19.
of those 159 million people just 5492
had breakthrough cases that resulted in
serious illnesses including 1 000 who
died
that is less than 0.0007
of the vaccinated population meanwhile
of deaths from covenant 19 are among the
unvaccinated
okay so what that means is that
vaccination is extraordinarily
powerful it has done really well and
masking ain't going to change the
trajectory of this thing vaccination is
going to change the trajectory of this
thing
because once you're vaccinated you're
pretty much done i've been saying this
for a long time
and if you're a kid right now they're
talking about masking kids up again
which is nuts
okay i'm sorry it's crazy i have small
kids they should not be masking
the reason they should not be masking is
because number one they can't wear masks
properly number two
wearing a mask for a small child is
actually kind of damaging it restricts
their oxygen intake
number three they're dirty they're gross
have you seen a kid wear a mask
kids are dirty and gross anyway i have
three of them and now they've got a
piece of cloth on their face they're
spitting into all day
okay you're talking about for kids a
disease that is not
extremely dangerous you're talking about
a disease that has killed 340 kids
nationwide under the age of 18 that is a
cohort of 75 million people
okay with a much wider diagnosis of
covid than you get in a typical flu
season so when people say well yeah
fewer people die of the flu each year
if they're kids then die of coba that's
because fewer people get the flu
and get coveted because covert is much
more transmissible than the traditional
influenza that people
have in the winter for example okay
bottom line is the real reason they're
telling kids to mask up
is to protect adults okay here's the
thing if you're an adult and you didn't
get the vaccine my kid should not have
to mask because you didn't get the
vaccine
that's your decision you're free to make
it and by the way i have lots of friends
i know lots of people who have not
gotten the vaccine their
reasons range from the spurious to the
somewhat understandable
right some of them are like well you
know the vaccine is going to kill no
it's in all likelihood not going to kill
you
okay also and when i say in all
likelihood i mean vanishingly small
numbers of people
is there evidence that vaccines have
killed them okay
not a million people very very few
people okay
and then there are people who say
something else which is i'm young i'm
healthy covett is not likely to kill me
the vaccines are not likely to kill me
the vaccines don't even have full fda
authorization at this point they're
still emergency use authorization i'm
21.
i've weighed the balances and i think
that the risks of taking the vaccine
long term
maybe outweigh the risks of me even
getting coveted all right if that's your
decision that's your decision but the
point is my kid should not have to mask
for your decision because that's really
dumb
that's really really dumb okay so for
example you have cnn's doctor lyanna wen
and she's saying the mask mandates will
have to come here is dr liana wen saying
this on cnn
the cdc in the first place made the
right decision when it comes to the
science but they didn't take into
account human behavior
and i think there's something that
there's one thing that bind
administration can be doing right now
that would change the equation when it
comes to incentives and that's to use
proof of vaccination
if they could say get the vaccine you
have a proof of vaccination
you can take off your mask that would be
really
key and i also think that vaccine
mandates are something that will have to
come so she says we have to have vaccine
mandates and then we need proof of
vaccination or alternatively if you have
the vaccine you're a responsible adult
and if you didn't have the vaccine
you can do what you want and it's not
our job to save you
right it's not our job to construct all
of society so that we can make an excuse
for the decision you made and most
people by the way who don't get the
vaccine are perfectly willing to live
with that decision it's really by the
way amusing to watch the left shift on
this so the left
has gone fully to if you don't get the
vaccine i mean i've heard this from many
people on the left people with whom i'm
friends
if you don't get the vaccine and then
you get sick from covet we shouldn't
have to pay your bills
and i think to myself all right that's
fair enough how about that for the
entire health system
glad to see you here on the libertarian
side gang because it turns out
a lot of people have heart disease
because they ate crap for 50 years
how about you pay for your own it turns
out if you actually once you set up good
incentives for people to make good
health decisions you have to make them
own their own health decision so i'm
actually not even opposed to that
but that's because i'm in favor of
people taking responsibility for their
health their health decisions regardless
of whether you're talking about heart
disease
or coven it's it is amazing to watch the
biden administration
shifting back toward all of the the
masking power
again they've made it political the
notion that the right wing is made up
political is just
crazy ron desantis has been as
pro-vaccine as any governor in america
right now i'm looking at the vaccination
rates in
in florida the vaccination rates in
florida if you're 85 years old or older
76 of that population has gotten one
dose 63 percent of that population has
been fully vaccinated
if you're 75 to 84 84 of that population
has gotten at least one dose the fully
vaccinated constitutes 72
of the population if you're 70 65 to 74
89 percent of that population has gotten
one dose 77 percent of that population
is fully vaccinated and then it starts
to decrease by age so that by the time
you get to say 25 to 34
only about 36 of that population has
gotten a dose
why because people are making decisions
based on their age
in fact the the risk of covid by age
is if everyone were unvaccinated looks
very much like the chart of vaccination
because people respond
to the incentive that covet itself
provides here is ron desantis saying
florida is not going to require kids to
mask because there is
no rationale for this there's been talk
about
potentially people advocating at the
federal level
imposing compulsory masks on kids
we're not doing that in florida okay at
the end of the day
uh we got to start putting our kids
first we got to look out for their
education
is it really comfortable is it really
healthy for them to be
muzzled and have their breathing
obstructed all day long in school
i don't think it is and i look to thank
you i have a three-year-old son
you got people like fauci saying he
should be muzzled that you should be
throwing mass on these three-year-old
kids
it's totally unacceptable
he's exactly correct about this but this
drove the white house in jensaki to say
desantis is putting kids at risk
if i were a parent in florida that would
be greatly concerning to me
uh because kids under the age of 12 are
not vaccinated they're not eligible yet
as the president said last night
obviously it's going to be led by the
fda but
certainly we hope that will be soon but
that puts kids at risk it's not aligned
with public health guidelines
we know masks are not the most
comfortable thing
i will say my kids are quite adjusted to
them as i know many kids are
so certainly we would have concern about
any step that doesn't abide by public
health guidelines and we think it puts
people back greater risk
maddening and insane maddening insane
puts people at greater risk who the kids
because we've been getting this
throughout the pandemic and the kids are
okay
okay by and large kids are are okay much
more okay with this than they are by the
way from pneumonia
but in the end here's the thing about
the radicalism of the
democratic public policy it's all
justified because republicans are bad
here was joe biden yesterday being asked
a tough question and then saying well
you know what it doesn't matter
because after all republicans think
we're going to suck the blood out of
children
man oh man
are there people in the republican party
who think we're sucking the blood out of
kids
i i'm i'm not sure are there people in
the democratic party who want to get the
president
in other words they can be as radical as
they want to be because republicans are
bad and
all republicans are queueing on and
everyone in the republican party is
crazy so we never have to tackle our own
radicalism
okay guys you're gonna pay the price for
this in 2022 go for it
seriously embrace the suck because it's
coming and it's coming up for you
we'll be back here later today with an
additional hour of content first you
can't forget to end your week by
checking out the andrew clavin show
drew's shows every friday he's got an
exciting evening planned for you so head
on over to dailywire.com
at 7 pm eastern 6 p.m central tune in
i'm bench pro this is the ben shapiro
show
the ben shapiro show is produced by
elliot feld executive producer jeremy
boring
our supervising producer is mathis
glover production manager pavel wydowsky
associate producer bradford carrington
host producer justin barber the show is
edited by adam sciovitz
audio is mixed by mike caromina her
makeup is by fabiola cristina
production assistant jessica kranz the
ben shapiro show is a daily wire
production
copyright daily wire 2021
john bickley here editor-in-chief of the
daily wire
wake up every morning with our new show
morning wire
on today's episode the tokyo olympics
officially kick
off hollywood attempts a box office
comeback
and the new space race begins join us
and get the facts first on the news you
need to know
with our show morning wire